never forget when china tried to buy you
you remember that i do as funny as it
sounds i'm not even bullshitting right
now they remember where we were at when
the email came in we were in dallas uh
texas and addison office so at least i
remember call that so creepiest they
were the creepiest zoom we ever they
offered you i think a quarter million
dollars to speak i have the email till
today and then another quarter million
dollars that you're gonna donate
something i don't wanna tell the story
yeah he says look we wanna fly you out
to china because this charity we're
willing to give you six hundred thousand
dollars of which we want you to present
a three hundred thousand dollar check
out of your bank account
to us but you're gonna net three hundred
thousand dollars we're gonna treat you
royally and an email came out
mario and i and a couple of our guys uh
got on the zoom with them
it was a pr firm out of new york with
uh folks in china to give six hundred
thousand dollars and said i'm like
i just wanted to hear them out to see
like are people actually saying yes to
this and then what is your outcome
is it later on in case because we're
allowed against you for you to come back
and say well he came to china gave us
three hundred thousand dollars to
charity so he was a supporter and sure
all this other stuff so you know it's
but but you got to realize so if
somebody to somebody of 600 000 a lot of
money to somebody like oh you know i'm
going to go out there and take a look at
this but man a lot of americans are
being sold to china a lot of americans
are being supposed to come back with a
counter offer after you told them no no
it was a very awkward zoom and the man
was a very uh there was nothing pleasant
the two publicies were very pleasant
there was nothing pleasant about the guy
it was very uncomfortable who was the
guy do you recall like
we have the name of the email but the
guy was very
disturbing and you can understand think
about that pr agency you answered your
own question do people really take the
money that's what they're doing an
american pr agency representing china
interest trying to suck in influencers
and wealthy people here in the u.s so
they can put them in their back pocket
for when they're needed listen i mean we
we
uh uh criticize prostitutes in america a
lot
and they you know they chose to live a
life for ex changing whatever they're
doing you know sex for money
but there's a the real prostitutes are
in hollywood and and and sports that are
taking bigger checks and they're selling
their souls and their country to any
country that's willing to pay the money
so you know we have to kind of uh if
you're really going to talk about
prostitutes you got to really go to the
point where these guys are getting paid
some real money to sell their country
sell their country other people that
yeah that to me
[Music]
that's that's i mean that's just you
know do you ever see a time where people
like that can be potentially tried for
treasonous activity
i don't think that'll happen because
there's ways to
cover through it but but but just just
think about it from the standpoint
to be bought for the rest of your life
no matter what the dollar amount is you
bet like look what happened to the devil
look what happened with what's his name
uh who just stepped down from uh uh
who's the guy that just stepped down the
the big wrestling ceo
they forced this guy to step down okay
what did he do behind closed doors he
bought him what's the number now it's
like 14.28 million i don't know what the
number is yeah
how many people he bought out and how
many people he did that okay
so what's the what's the solution you
know what's the alternative do you know
what the real alternative is hey if you
don't come in i'm going to tell the
world about it here's the reality if
anybody ever threatens you
that they're going to tell you about you
hooked up with them you should tell them
look you're eventually going to tell him
so if you're going to ruin my marriage
now or three years from now just go
running i'm not giving you [ __ ] yeah
because you're going to tell the world
so you know what matter of fact let's do
three-way with my wife go ahead hey babe
i just wanna tell you i screwed up
here's a lady i was looking at a
three-way totally different right okay
and by the way but i know
i'm telling you this i'm
i'm telling you you're a freer man to
take that approach than to take this
approach
every single month you have to be
waiting for somebody to say i want to
bring this out and and take it public
and tell you tell this tell them it
seems like kind of a weak way for vince
to go down doesn't it a little bit i
mean the guy was such a hard charger
he's the face of wrestling no one's been
more important in the sport than him
yeah but what's the story he he was
having the board is basically forcing
him because he was
paying women under the table because he
was having sex with relationships
relationships covering things up so was
he paying out of his own money or yeah i
think he was paying his own money so
what's the problem here exactly well
time to go extra marital affairs it's a
bad look it's bad pr i mean well his
wife you know ran for senate in
connecticut i mean she she had a high
profile herself she had a big role in
wwe too so maybe they all just
collectively felt it's time to move on
let's stephanie and triple h i respect
them and that's their business
if if they're having the conversations
right now and the wife is saying the
hell is the matter with you
you know i understand all this other
stuff what are you doing and they're
gonna have their whatever and they're
going to say you know what this is what
we're doing we're either getting a
divorce or you got to step away yeah
because this is embarrassing the entire
family so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]